all right heinz yes hi where'd you grow
up where are you from i grew up i'm from
greenwood mississippi i grew up yeah i
grew up in greenwood mississippi and uh
tell me about your childhood do you grew
up with both your parents no
um my father got he got a
mess up in in in the war in world war ii
right he got messed up in the water and
uh he had complications from that and he
died at the veteran hospital in uh
memphis tennessee
i was like i was one year old i was one
you know when he died right
and my mother she died when i was like
i was in the uh fifth grade i was going
on two years old but she died unnatural
you know she got a natural death you
know
so i raised i raised by my aunt you know
founded me was you know one man on mary
i raised we were raised by her you know
how would you describe your childhood my
childhood was good you know i went to uh
i went to catholic school
you know
and my auntie had taken us out of the
public school
because like um i was failing in my math
and she shouted out to uh where they
might have assisted them going to
catholic school anyway so they shot me
into the arch count this school but i
grew up
my childhood was good because like
uh
greenwood mississippi you know in
mississippi at that time is racism you
know you got this this side of the track
that side of the track well i got auntie
auntie um one of my teachers she got two
kids had two boys
it was like my mother age right my
cousins and they happened to be a white
guy right
you know she got too hard breathing and
they um
and over his name across oh man crocker
he owned he owned land he owned a
plantation and all that so they you know
they had what they want to have monty
had owned a black hotel in greenwood
mississippi right
you don't want anybody to come there
famous black and they stay they come
stay nowhere but they have to stay in
that in uh hotel plaza which i helped
you know run you know and all that you
know growing up and everything
you know i met uh growing up i met a lot
of blues players you know singers and
stuff you're on the mississippi river
there uh miss little really that's a
little father for me we got the yazoo
river and that oh i see
i grew up my child like i said i had a
damn good childhood my you know my folks
are well off you know i didn't have no
problem you know throwing up no
mental problems you know abuse any of
that you know none of that you know
i grew up
i grew up during the civil rights
movement
and if you if anybody familiar with you
wouldn't say a right movement greenwood
mississippi was a hotbed that's where
you had that white counselor the white
council they want supported that racism
to the clan and all that uh if you're
familiar with mega mega evans the one
that uh uh got shot by becker
doing the 60. wait wait big one the uh
white guy that shot him and killed him
from us from my own town
you know they when uh when they like
like uh back in the days
a white couldn't get convicted from
killing the black so when when he got
free they had mcdonald's over the city
you know why come home welcome home so
you can imagine how we black fell you
know they had a big celebration
you know but um
like i said i have no problem growing up
you know my my my childhood you know was
good
you know like they said i got this coach
got this hotel that we running
you know and i'm gonna you know i grew
up auntie one of my moms you don't know
tells you that snatch me you know help
me go with it you know there's a ride i
want to collect rent stuff like that you
know and like i said i met a lot of
singers blue player called my cousin he
booked a lot of them you know and they
and they threw dances and stuff like
that concerts you know so i was right
there
but as i grew up you know like
i don't know the city you know that type
that type of integration and that type
of living it just went for me some guy
telling me that i got to go
you know so at a young age
at 17 i signed up for the you know put
on it you know i signed up and uh i went
i don't know when i went to the military
it was um
my mos would uh
level bravo 11 bravo his infantry
you know my cousin and my brother you
know they went off on me by being you
know infantry but i had made a statement
say if i do go to vietnam i want to go
in with some action and i don't go to be
a clerk or truck driver you know or a
cook you know i want to see some action
and when i got over that scene action
boy i would sell water cook
you know
i stayed in vietnam
for about what about 18 months
you know i had a lot of homeboys that
got killed you know
and i i've seen
i've seen a lot of stuff in vietnam did
a lot of stuff that things that
that we hardly ever talk about you know
because a lot a lot of stuff like we can
say that we have a conversation you say
oh he bush and you know but you know
it's real stuff you know
and [ __ ] and like i would like i tried
i tried i turned 18
in full pork louisiana
i turned 19 in vietnam
you know i was a youngster you know and
then when i got over seeing all this you
know seeing this there's all this depth
you know it's you know it was a trip you
know it messed me up into mine that's
the first time i i used drugs
i never used drugs i didn't go around i
didn't grow up around drugs
you know i got to numb when i got to
their mom i started you know
using drugs
you know
and it had effect you know but then
era
it was
opium they had harry on but i i was like
i was i didn't fail and the jungle was
right i'm out there fighting so we not
back there you know what we had to
contact to get her on right we get opium
right and we smoke you know
some guy just shot it but i can see
shooting i smoked it you know and stuff
you know and
but you know like
i said hardest man but you need
something right some people can go
through it some can't sometimes you know
you need something you know to ease your
mind you know going out and see you know
i've been in some [ __ ] that when i come
back you know come back out right
and come back to the to the main base
you know i'm sitting down and tripping
you know man
you know you go out you got 30 guys
and you lose you lose nine of them
you know it's a trip you know i um
i experienced
like
we we was on patrol when we was on
patrol one day
and
we had a sergeant i didn't like i didn't
like it you know because he appeared to
i got busted he had taken my uh position
so i didn't you know
i didn't like him and
we went out we went out one day
and he was all decided you know and all
his right talking i don't want to hear
that [ __ ] but anyway we walk into ambush
right we walk into a u-shaped mountain
bush you know
and
as we fighting and stuff he come running
over that you know bible's right coming
man do you see that did you see that you
know i almost got hit you know
like
i'm saying i'm standing like this right
i'm standing like this
he come right beside me you know what
i'm saying
no he was on this side that's right
she's standing right here right and he's
talking you know man do you see that
[ __ ] see that and i look i mean i want
to hear that [ __ ]
and i'm trying to kill my gunner right
my machine's on the right i said come on
man let's get away from this
man that's not god the truth no sooner i
did this man someone got shot right here
no soon i mean he's standing right here
man
you know no soon i step
boom i look oh my god
you know that's traumatizing yeah you
know
that's a trip you know
and you know a lot
like
we were you know we had ran into a lot
we were there we were doing we were
doing um
ambushes ourselves you know the company
that i work with that's what we did we
went on patrol we set up you know and we
set up ambushes you know but you know
you know
it take a heart
you know it he got
you know
the trap you know it's trying to
transfer
it
you know it take it you know you got you
got to be uh built a certain way you
know that's to shoot a man you know
you know you know what i'm saying he
come in man walking down and said boom
boom but over there you learn
you know they they put that in you it's
uh like growing up
like i said growing up life
like they mean [ __ ]
you know
if someone step on your shoe
[ __ ] it you know i'm saying growing up
like one you know
but when i went to vietnam
you know around my granddad and my
grandma and all that when he died you
know but i don't know what it just
when i went there it was just a certain
deal you know what i'm saying i saw
death you know right you know i'm
talking to you right now so you did boom
like that and
you know that that made me change my
whole life like appreciate life
you know you look at my life it's
beautiful you know whatever certain
thing that we are living on it life is
still it's beautiful you know what i'm
saying to live you know and i learned
you know i learned you know i learned to
respect life
you know you just don't take nobody like
for the hell up you know for the
[ __ ] you know i learned you know a
lot of i respect like you know
uh
i left i left i um
i left vietnam
and went back to mississippi
and
like i said i grew up i grew up around i
grew up there i came in the 60s right
you know there was so much racism there
you know it was pathetic you know
you know like i said it was so much you
know
it was you know it was a trip i couldn't
i couldn't sleep you know so i went back
i went i used to i grew up in singalore
soon you know so went i went to saint
louis you know with my sister
and then i stayed up little about about
a year and i came out here
you know i got in school you know and uh
i was working juvenile hall you know
but i had a problem you know i had a
problem that i didn't know
you know
i was suffering from from from you know
probably i didn't know i had you know
because
i'd be doing all right
then all of a sudden i go back to the
drugs
like i said i never use drugs
i was in vietnam you know and all of a
sudden you know i go back to these drugs
so when i when i went out to the va
and you know i started getting treatment
for it i found out you know what you
know the problem was that for some
reason
that's why they take me back to the
jungles of vietnam you know if i come
out here right and i started having
problems
i'd go back to use a drug you know it
take me back to vietnam
you know because i know i said uh i got
a serious case of the ptsd
i'm gonna stand right here and it
started raining
and take me back to the monsoon season
and we out here in helicopter getting
fly by you know and it takes me back
you know it's a trip you know i had i
had job job working at the va working at
the uh specific phone company and stuff
you know but like i said
i run to a brick wall for some reason i
go back you know i i go back and use it
and what it is like i feel like i got a
lot i left something in vietnam like i
said i turned eighteen four poke i
turned nineteen in vietnam and it feel
like i left left the youth and that kid
in me
over there because someday
they keep calling me back keep calling
me keep calling me you know and you know
it hurts me you know
but that
over years you know over the years i
want i wind up homeless
you know now i've been down here
off and on since the 70s
right i've seen this change i've seen a
lot of problems i got three boys i
raised i raped three boys
here
on drugs right they went to school every
day
right you know clean and everything they
have no problem they went to school
every day they graduated you know one of
them working on a phd now
you know i did all the i did all this
right downtire sometimes we like
sometimes we get homeless we got to pull
up better than [ __ ] up so sometimes we
got hate
you know but uh
it's it's what you instill into a kid
how you raise the kid
you know like i said they come right
down with the ninth street school
and all that you know and you'd be
surprised how they turn out you you know
one i got a son heinz who kind of the
third you know
he ought to do that dj stuff
you know he'd be over here on the side
now trying to do a show all kinds of
stuff he's doing you know
the trip yeah
and your drug today is heroin
yeah well i was on that run right i was
on off and on for years
but i came out this time
i went to a program i took myself to
program i went to a program i stayed in
the program
about what
14 months
right
and when i come out this time
somebody around people around people
they're smoking the uh they're fitting
all so i started smoking a few no you
know what i'm doing that you know
you know
be careful
i know had to be careful you know i'm
thinking about i'll get i think i got to
get back into a program you know
and what i got to do
you know
and so you know how
i don't know you know i just turned 71
years you know sitting on one man that's
i ain't think i'll live this long
your years on skid row yeah your decades
on skid row yeah but right it's off and
on off and on right how have you spent
the last
40 years or so last four years i spent
uh
i spent right over here uh the
continental right right before i went to
the program i was with continental right
i stayed i had a place i had a basement
the basement you know you know i haven't
you know
i had i had that that's why i stayed at
and then i caught a case
a sales case
you're selling drugs you gotta sell the
drugs i call the case you know so i went
to uh i went to court and i went to
veteran court and by me being invested
they shot me into a program
so i went to the program and stayed at
14 about 15 months
and i come up this time and messed up
you know i was cool for a minute
where are you sleeping now in my car
you're sitting in your car i'm sleeping
in my car with my dog yeah
yeah
you know i don't have you know i don't
have a place to go i'll get ready to
check out they they gotta
they they got uh
organization that the house you know
they put you up you know i'm just gonna
try to you know get some information on
that
this thing you know
and you know so looking back at your
life
what were the i mean the pivotal points
were probably vietnam
that would change you're losing your
parents vietnam
yeah you had some big
addictive points right i was uh
in 1885 right
1985 i was down i was uh i
i was down here right and they
but i moved to van nuys
right nice pad everything right you know
i'm hustling whatever
and uh
i get a cat i come down one saturday
and somebody snitched on me posed you
take my keys went in my trunk and got i
don't know about
ten thousand cody's number four right so
i go to jail you know for that
so
while i'm in jail
i got the two bedroom
apartment right two bedroom apartment
band eyes yeah on haskell
muffler went in my house man and kept my
lady man
you know my older boy he was like
he was like six at the time
and my
mother's boy she had just had him just
had it are you about to two or three
months old you know she just had him and
do
doing in my house and did that you know
he did what he killed my woman oh he
killed your
your wife
my my my leader used it was
right your girlfriend you know my
girlfriend right we we had just had a a
boy right mother father
the mother of your son yeah the mother
my son you know
i'm in jail and homicide coming you know
they tell me you know
you know that's a [ __ ] up feeling
you know i was lucky it was like i
hadn't got census you know on anything
so they bailed me out right i get bailed
out you know because that go to child
custody all that kind of stuff but this
this
kind of effect you know
and stuff
you know
like you know that that happened like
well i took kids i really i kept on kids
you know i raised them you know i just i
bought them to do that you know i'm
saying uh
my old son he remembered
because he fought with the guy
you know he got threw him against the
wall and told him get your butt in
bedroom
you know you don't know he's scared you
know
and you know when you come out his mom
that's what he called his mother she
wasn't emotionally raised and though
and he said my mom was dead you know
and i you know
i actually see the pictures
they told me no you don't want to see
the pictures it won't be a good idea i
said no let me see the pictures
i saw the fishing that [ __ ] me up
you know
yeah you know yeah shuttle throat
stuff try it what do you suppose that
was over i don't know he tried to rape
her but he didn't
you know she always said if anybody ever
tried to rape me they got killed me well
i pray i pray to god i wish you
you know you know i wish you would do it
let it have it you know what i'm saying
you know to die you know you know you
know i just took care of it you know
yeah anything like that happened but i
you know
i kept my boy so you know i kept my boys
kept on together and everything you know
where do i like you live oh yeah yeah
well i've been through i've been through
some of the trauma you know
and stuff but somehow like i say i came
through you know but then i go back
what i get might go by using you know
what what's the most important thing
you've learned in your life
like
most important thing i learned in my
life is that you know
life is beautiful man
you know
i learned people that you that you
people incompetent that you keep
you know
and then
one thing i learned how to appreciate
things
you know how to how to how to you know
appreciate you know like i said like
if you've been around
this world
in life man uh wherever you at man it's
beautiful it's it's beautiful right
you know you're gonna have all kind of
fun you know you know and you can look
you go and look at it you know the
mountains and all that i learned how to
appreciate life you know you look at all
these beautiful things that god
put here for us
you know you believe in god whatever but
you put all this natural all this nice
everything nice you know this is for you
all here
and he asks for one thing he actually
and we can't even do that that's love
one another
you know
you can't even do that we can't even
love one another we got all this stuff
all this beautiful thing that i learned
you know i learned how to respect life
how to reach
how to respect the nice man you know
although i grew up
in the race area right you know where
they were hanging blacks and castrating
blacks and all that i don't have that
prejudice
you know what i'm saying i learned how
to respect the nation you know you treat
me you know you know the way that you
treat me i treat you
you know it's a problem i back up
go the other way
you know if i run into any kind of you
know i learned that i'm running any kind
of problem just trying to go the other
way you know i say remove myself from it
you know
all right heinz thank you so much for
sharing your story okay
good so yeah i mean
i i
i thought about i could drive by you
know
um maybe
once a week or something just talk to
you you know you get more
you